- There is no other way to put it.
Roe v. Wade and its progeny are dead.
Women in the United States no longer have
a constitutional guaranteed
right to an abortion.
This video explains the how and the why
of everything that happened.
And to do that, we have
to start with the history
of how we got Roe v.
Wade in the first place.
What is the source of
a constitutional right
to an abortion in the United States?
It is one of the rights which fall under
a general right to privacy,
which is the right of people
to make personal decisions
regarding intimate matters.
Now, when you're talking
about the right to privacy,
you're talking about unenumerated rights
in the constitution.
When the founders were
drafting the constitution,
they did not set out to
list all of the rights
which Americans could conceivably claim.
They were well aware that
by naming some of the rights
but not others, future governments
might deny the people rights
that the founders believed were important.
And this is why the Federalists
originally did not want
a bill of rights to be included
in the constitution itself.
And as a compromise, rather
than make a long list of rights,
the founders included the Ninth Amendment,
which states, quote, "The
enumeration in the constitution,
of certain rights, shall not be construed
to deny or disparage others
retained by the people."
James Madison in
particular reportedly said
that the government should
never use the bill of rights
as an excuse to increase its powers
over areas of life that
were not enumerated
in the constitution.
Now, the Supreme Court
really began fleshing out
unenumerated rights in
the mid 20th century,
particularly in a case called
Griswold v. Connecticut,
which voided a statute
that made it illegal
for married people to buy contraception.
The Court wrote that privacy
was one of the values
implied by the First Amendment,
which protects the right of
association between people,
by the Fourth Amendment,
which allows people to be
secure in their persons
from government intrusions
and through the 14th Amendment's
guarantee of due process.
Now, in that case, after
reviewing a line of cases
in which the Supreme
Court identified rights
not explicitly enumerated
in the constitution,
Justice Douglas argued that the Court
could infer a right to privacy
by looking at zones of privacy
protected by other parts
of the constitution
in overlapping protections.
Quote, "Various guarantees
create zones of privacy.
The right of association
contained in the penumbra
of the First Amendment
is one, as we have seen.
The Third Amendment in its
prohibition against quartering
of soldiers in any house in time of peace
without the consent of the owner
is another facet of that privacy.
The Fourth Amendment explicitly affirms
the right of the people to
be secure in their persons,
houses, papers, and effects,
against unreasonable
searches and seizures.
The Fifth Amendment in its
Self-Incrimination Clause
enables the citizen to
create a zone of privacy
which government may not
force him to surrender
to his detriment.
The Ninth Amendment
provides the enumeration
in the Constitution, of certain rights,
shall not be construed
to deny or disparage
others retained by the people."
Now, Griswold upheld the
right of married couples
to decide private issues of contraception.
And seven years later, Eisenstadt v. Baird
extended Griswold's
holding to unmarried people
using some of the same logic.
And following Griswold, the Court upheld
a right to privacy and
struck down a number of laws,
including those prohibiting
interracial marriage.
The constitution does not explicitly say
anything about marriage.
And in the mid 19th century,
the law offered interracial
couples no protection
even from prosecution.
In Loving v. Virginia, the Court held
that a Virginia law criminalizing
interracial marriage
violated the due process
clause of the 14th Amendment.
Chief Justice Earl Warren wrote,
"Under our constitution
the freedom to marry
or not marry a person of another race
resides with the individual
and cannot be infringed by the state."
And continuing with that
logic, the Court also relied
on the 14th Amendment's due process laws
to strike down laws banning prisoners
from getting married while in prison.
And in continuing in those
line of cases, in 1973,
Roe v. Wade established
a constitutional right
to an abortion through the
Fifth Amendment, among others.
And the Fifth Amendment says
no person shall be deprived
of life, liberty, or property
without due process of law.
Now, courts have interpreted
two types of due process.
One is procedural due process,
which are the rules that
the government must follow,
such as giving a person notice, a hearing,
and a fair tribunal.
And then there's what's called
the substantive due process,
which is the idea that allows courts
to establish and protect
certain fundamental rights
from government interference
even if procedural protections are present
or the rights are unenumerated.
Now, the Roe opinion
begins with the long review
of the medical history of abortion.
It reviews the history of abortion laws,
finding that many prohibitions on abortion
were relatively modern.
The Court reviewed many religious
and philosophical traditions,
which contain many different views
about when or if the unborn
could be considered people
during different stages of pregnancy.
And the Court ruled that the word person,
as used in the constitution,
did not include the unborn.
The Court concluded that
the 14th Amendment's concept
of personal liberty includes
a right of personal privacy
over certain areas, which include
whether a woman terminates
a pregnancy or not.
And the Court also recognized
that the government
could not make a choice
about whether the person
continues a pregnancy.
And the Court held that the
state had valid interest
that justified regulation of pregnancy,
and that the state's interest increased
as the pregnancy progressed.
Then almost 20 years later,
the Supreme Court decided
another abortion case that
substantially revised Roe,
that's Planned Parenthood v. Casey.
That case tested whether
states had the right
to restrict abortion, including
during the first trimester.
The Pennsylvania regulations included
a mandatory waiting period,
spousal notification,
and parental consent.
In the Casey decision, the
Supreme Court overturned
Roe's trimester rule in favor
of a viability analysis,
and lowered the standard of
review for abortion restrictions
from strict scrutiny to
an undue burden test.
And under Casey's undue burden test,
abortion restrictions
were unconstitutional
if they had the purpose or effect
of placing a substantial obstacle
in the path of a woman seeking an abortion
of a non-viable fetus.
The Court held that states
could require parental consent
for a minor's abortion,
require waiting period
between seeking and obtaining an abortion,
and require detailed informed consent,
including medical information
about the abortion.
But the state couldn't require a woman
to sign a form stating
that she had given notice
to her husband that she
was having an abortion.
And again, following in
these cases, in 2003,
the Supreme Court cited
Loving, Griswold, Eisenstadt,
Casey, and Roe in
striking down a Texas law
that criminalized sexual
intimacy by same sex couples
but not identical conduct
by straight couples.
The Court held that the law violated
the 14th Amendment's Due Process Clause
as adults are free to
engage in private conduct
in the exercise of their liberty
under the Due Process Clause.
Quote, "Their right to liberty
under the Due Process Clause
gives them the full right
to engage in their conduct
without intervention of the government."
And notably, Justice Scalia
dissented in this case,
stating that the logic of the decision
would of course permit same-sex marriage.
And in 2012, following in that case,
the Court proved him right by
legalizing same-sex marriage,
citing the same string
of cases that established
the right to choose one's
intimate relationships
and whether to have children.
And when the Court decided that
case, Obergefell v. Hodges,
it observed that if a person
has the right to choose
whether to have an abortion,
then they have the right to marry
the person of their choice.
Now, in the aftermath of
Planned Parenthood v. Casey,
states enacted more and more restrictions
on the right to an abortion.
Over the years, federal
courts have analyzed
nearly every kind of abortion
restriction imaginable,
invalidating some of them
and upholding others.
But one thing never changed,
the Court's original ruling
that the right to privacy
included the right to illegal abortion.
But the recent case
of Dobbs v. Jackson
Women's Health Organization
changed all of that.
The Jackson Women's Health Organization
brought this lawsuit to challenge
the constitutionality of
Mississippi's Gestational Age Act,
which states, "Except
in a medical emergency
or in the case of a
severe fetal abnormality,
a person shall not intentionally
or knowingly perform
or induce an abortion
of an unborn human being
if the probable gestational
age of the unborn human being
has been determined to be
greater than 15 weeks."
Jackson Women's Health
was the only remaining
abortion clinic in the state.
The organization won at the
federal district court level,
and the district court decision was upheld
by the Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals.
Mississippi appealed to the Supreme Court.
Now, some legal commentators
expected the Supreme Court
to simply overturn
Casey's viability analysis
and replace it with a right to an abortion
that stops at 15 weeks.
And in fact, this is what
Justice Roberts advocated
in his concurring opinion.
However, a majority of the Supreme Court
decided to overrule Roe
and Casey from the roots
and allow each state to decide
whether there is a right
to an abortion or not.
The majority opinion was
written by Justice Alito,
and the vote to overturn
Roe was five to four.
Justices Thomas, Gorsuch,
Kavanaugh, and Barrett
joined Alito's opinion.
Chief Justice John Roberts
did not join in the opinion
in overturning Roe but filed
a separate concurring opinion,
which he agreed with the result,
which is why you'll see
some people call this
a six to three decision.
Justices Kagan, Sotomayor,
and Breyer dissented.
Now, Justice Alito's
opinion begins by stating
that abortion presents
a profound moral issue
on which Americans hold
sharply conflicting views.
The Constitution's text
does not refer to abortion.
Alito concedes that not
all rights recognized
by the Court have to be mentioned
in the Constitution's text.
As I explained earlier, the Court has held
that due process guarantees
of the 5th and 14th Amendments
protect certain substantive rights
that are not listed in the constitution.
The general idea is that certain liberties
are so important that the
state cannot infringe on them
without a compelling reason,
no matter how much procedural
due process is given.
And Justice Alito states
that the Due Process Clause
protects the right to
interracial marriage,
the right to use contraception,
and the right to same-sex marriage,
but it does not guarantee
the right to abortion.
Why?
Well, according to the majority,
the test for unenumerated
rights is whether the right
is deeply rooted in the
nation's history and tradition
and implicit in the
concept of ordered liberty.
And according to Justice Alito,
abortion doesn't qualify
under that standard.
And in setting forth this test
for which unenumerated
rights are permissible,
Alito cites Washington v. Glucksberg,
the case which found that there
was no constitutional right
to a physician-assisted suicide.
Abortion is like assisted suicide because,
according to the majority,
neither can trace their roots
to the founding of America.
The Alito opinion goes on at great length
about the history of abortion in America.
He states that until the latter
part of the 20th century,
such a right was entirely
unknown in American law.
And indeed, when the 14th
Amendment was adopted,
three quarters of the
states made abortion a crime
at all stages of pregnancy.
And the majority opinion
says that the 50 years
between Roe and the present day
do not carry any weight in establishing
that that right is deeply rooted
or that women relied on it
in organizing their lives.
The majority opinion
concludes that Roe's holding
that abortion was a liberty interest
protected by due process was incorrect.
The Roe decision said,
quote, "The right of privacy,
whether it be founded in
the 14th Amendment's concept
of personal liberty and
restrictions upon state action,
as we feel it is, or as the
district court determined
in the Ninth Amendment's preservation
of rights to the people,
is broad enough to
encompass a woman's decision
whether or not to terminate her pregnancy.
Now, Alito criticized the
justices who wrote this,
saying that they couldn't
really put their finger
on the nature of the right and
it was decided on feelings.
And then there's always
been controversy about that.
In fact, many commentators have argued,
the Court made a mistake in grounding
the right to an abortion
in the substance of Due Process Clause.
Justice Ginsburg argued that the Court
should have decided Roe based
on the Equal Protection Clause
or the Privileges and Immunities Clause,
which would've provided
a more durable protection
of the right.
And in Dobbs, several
constitutional law professors
filed amicus briefs, arguing
that the right to an abortion
is rooted in the Equal Protection Clause.
But Justice Alito said that
the Equal Protection Clause
is inapplicable because
the Court had already ruled
that abortion is not a
sex-based classification.
Justice Alito rejected calls
to preserve Roe and Casey
because of stare decisis.
He said that the concept
is not a straight jacket
when a ruling is grievously incorrect,
and listed other landmark decisions
which upended precedent like
Brown v. Board of Education,
which overruled Plessy
v. Ferguson's separate
but equal doctrine.
And then there was stare decisis,
the idea that the Court
should follow precedent
to foster predictability
unless it has a very good reason not to.
And in assessing whether
stare decisis applied,
the Court looked to several factors,
the nature of the Court's error,
the quality of the reasoning,
the workability of the standard,
it's effect on other parts of the law,
and reliance interests.
Justice Alito said stare
decisis was not applicable
because the original Roe
decision, as modified by Casey,
is, quote, "Egregiously wrong."
In support of its decision,
the majority opinion
cites 30 other cases where the Court
has overturned prior precedent.
As to the five factors, Justice Alito said
that Roe was fundamentally unfair
because it foreclosed the opportunity
for anti-abortion advocates
to lobby their government for change.
Quote, "Those on the losing side,
those who sought to advance
the state's interest
in fetal life could no longer seek
to persuade their elected representatives
to adopt policies consistent
with their views,"
though the statement ignores the decades
of law-making around abortion,
where legislatures passed
abortion restrictions
in response to the democratic process.
And as to the workability factor,
Alito said that as a practical matter,
the undue burden test was
too confusing to apply.
Though he also criticized Roe's
original trimester framework
as being plucked out of nowhere.
And in a stunningly short section,
Alito wrote that overturning the precedent
would not hurt women
because there's no evidence
that women rely on the right to abortion
in living their lives.
He said, quote, "Conventional
concrete reliance interests
are not present here."
And he concluded that
the right to an abortion
had nothing in common with
other types of interest
that people rely on, like
contract and property rights,
because abortion is unplanned.
And he said that if women
really think they rely
on the right to abortion,
they should vote.
He dismissed generalized
issues of reliance
by saying the Court is ill-equipped
to assess generalized assertions
about the national psyche.
Now, obviously, four other
justices, Roberts, Sotomayor,
Kagan, and Breyer, criticized the majority
for overruling two
longstanding precedents.
Justice Roberts' concurring opinion,
which we'll talk about more in a second,
supported upholding Roe
because of stare decisis.
And meanwhile, the dissenters disagreed
with the majority's
conclusion that it can reverse
these abortion cases without undermining
other fundamental rights.
They wrote, quote, "Think
of someone telling you
that the Jenga tower
simply will not collapse."
However, Justice Alito
addressed their concerns
by stating that the right
to same sex intimate acts,
the right to contraception,
and the right to same-sex marriage
were quantifiably different
than the right to an abortion.
Unlike those rights, abortion
terminates a human life.
It affects, quote, potential life.
Whereas, those other rights do not.
He said, quote, "Nothing in this opinion
should be understood to cast doubt
on precedents that do
not concern abortion."
Though it should be noted
that this distinction
between rights that
implicate potential life
is not in the constitution
and is not particularly well
supported in this context.
Justice Alito goes on to say
that since abortion doesn't
implicate any fundamental right,
then Mississippi's law
should not be judged
according to the heightened scrutiny
that the Court affords fundamental rights.
Instead, the majority opinion says
that abortion restrictions
should be judged
using the rational basis
standard of review,
which is the most lenient
standard of review.
Basically, almost no law
ever fails rational basis.
Now, it's relatively easy for state laws
to survive rational basis scrutiny.
The laws are upheld as long
as there is a rational basis,
which the legislature could have thought
it would serve the
legitimate state interest.
And Alito had no problem
finding that Mississippi statute
that met that standard since it asserted
the state's interest in
protecting the life of the unborn,
and because it regulated
the medical procedure
that is generally used for
abortions after the 15th week.
And therefore, the opinion concluded
the abortion providers'
challenge to the law had to fail.
And the Alito opinion did not
analyze a women's interest
in obtaining an abortion
after 15 weeks of pregnancy
because under the rational basis review,
the Court outlined it wasn't necessary
to the determination of this case.
And that takes us to
the Roberts concurrence.
Now, the concurrences and the dissents
do not carry the force of law.
There was a majority for the
Court and that is now the law.
But examining these other
concurrences and dissents
is interesting to let
us know where the court
might be going in the future
and what the other alternatives were.
With respect to the Roberts concurrence,
Chief Justice Roberts
agreed with the decision
to uphold the Mississippi law,
but he would've done so
without formally
overturning Roe and Casey.
Roberts was prepared to uphold
the constitutional right to an abortion,
but he would've eliminated
the viability analysis
that was in place in Casey.
He would've characterized Roe and Casey
as adopting two distinct
rules of constitutional law,
a woman's right to end a pregnancy
and the state's power to
override a woman's right
when a fetus becomes viable.
Justice Roberts said
that the viability line,
quote, "Never made any sense."
The right to terminate a pregnancy
should, quote, "extend far enough
to ensure a reasonable
opportunity to choose
but need not extend any further."
Roberts briefly surveys international law
and concludes that the general proposition
is to allow abortions
until around 12 to 15 weeks
without regard to the
viability of the fetus.
Roberts also points out that Mississippi
did not ask the Court to eliminate
the right to an abortion.
The basic request was straightforward.
He wrote that it was to clarify
whether abortion
prohibitions before viability
are always unconstitutional.
For Roberts, all of
these factors indicated
that the best way to balance the interest
was to use judicial restraint.
He would've eliminated
the viability standard
but upheld the right to an abortion.
Justice Roberts first
suggested this compromise
during oral arguments,
but he was unable to sway
the five other justices.
Then there are the concurrences
from Justices Kavanaugh and Thomas.
Justice Brett Kavanaugh
said that in his view,
the constitution is neutral on abortion.
Since the constitution is neutral,
then, quote, "This Court
must also be scrupulously
neutral about abortion."
Kavanaugh emphasized that the Court
wasn't outlawing abortion nationwide
and was instead leaving
the decision to the states.
He wrote that the nine
unelected members of this Court
do not possess the
constitutional authority
to override a democratic process
and to decree either pro-life
or pro-choice abortion policy
for all 330 people living
in the United States.
The rest of Kavanaugh's
opinion was designed
to reassure people that this
wasn't a radical opinion
that would upend other cases
like Griswold and Obergefell.
And he anticipates some
of the major legal issues
that are probably coming,
particularly whether a
state can ban its residents
from traveling to another
state to obtain an abortion,
or whether a state can
retroactively punish people
who had abortions.
He says that these are not hard questions.
The answer to both of them is no.
Though this is just a concurrence,
these answers in this
concurrence have no legal weight
since these questions
were before the Court
and no other justices
agreed with his conclusions.
So that takes us to Thomas' concurrence,
which is sort of the opposite
of Kavanaugh's concurrence.
Justice Thomas wrote
a concurrence to state
that while he agreed with
the majority opinion,
that there was never a due
process right to abortion.
The Court should also make it clear
that there was no such thing
as substantive due process at all.
Justice Thomas believes
that the Constitution's Due Process Clause
only addresses the processes
the government uses
before taking a person's
life, liberty, or property,
that it has nothing to
say about the substance
of the person's rights.
He left no doubt about what he thought
about rights to gay
marriage, contraception,
and same-sex intimate conduct.
Quote, "In future cases,
we should reconsider
all of the Court's substantive
due process precedents,
including Griswold,
Lawrence, and Obergefell.
Though critics noted that
Thomas did not address
the similar case of Loving v. Virginia,
the case that legalized
interracial marriage
and protects the legitimacy
of Thomas' own marriage.
It's hard to square a
deeply rooted analysis
with keeping Loving v. Virginia intact
if the Court is going to go after the rest
of the unenumerated rights cases.
However, Loving was also
grounded in equal protection.
It is related to but not totally dependent
on these substantive due process
cases he wants to overturn.
That takes us to the
dissent of Justices Breyer,
Sotomayor, and Kagan.
The dissenters critiqued
the majority's claim
that they were simply returning the issue
to state legislatures where it belongs.
Quote, "We believe in a constitution
that puts some issues off
limits to majority rule."
In other words, the
dissenting opinion warns
that it is dangerous for the majority
to have total control
over minority rights.
The dissent rejects Alito's
claim that Roe and Casey
just randomly appeared,
that they came from nowhere,
and went nowhere.
"This," they write, "is not true."
The dissenting opinion takes
issue with Alito's statement
that Casey and Roe didn't allow courts
to even consider whether the state
has an interest in promoting life.
And the dissent says
that part of the reason
that Casey had departed from
the Roe trimester analysis
was because the Court recognized
that after two decades,
the Roe framework did not
give states sufficient ability
to regulate abortion prior to viability.
Quote, "The strength of
those state interests
is exactly why the Court
allowed greater restrictions
on the abortion right than on other rights
derived from the 14th amendment."
The dissent goes on to say that, quote,
"What Roe and Casey also recognized,
which today's majority does not,
is that a woman's freedom and equality
are likewise involved.
That fact, the presence of
countervailing interest,
is what made the abortion question hard
and what necessitated balancing.
The majority scoffs at that idea,
castigating us for repeatedly
praising the balance
the two cases arrived at,
with the word balance in scare quotes.
To the majority, balance is a dirty word,
as moderation is a foreign concept."
The dissenters also disagreed
with Alito's insistence
that the right to an abortion
must be deeply rooted
in the country's history.
The Court, quote, "Makes this change
based on a single question,
did the reproductive right
recognized in Roe and Casey exist in 1868,
the year when the 14th
amendment was ratified.
The majority says, and
with this much we agree,
that the answer to this question is no.
In 1868, there was no nationwide right
to end a pregnancy and no thought
that the 14th Amendment provided one."
But the dissent concludes
that it doesn't make sense
to ask what was in the minds of the people
who ratified the amendment in 1868,
and more to the point, quote,
"People did not ratify the 14th Amendment.
Men did.
So it is perhaps not
surprising that the ratifiers
were not perfectly
attuned to the importance
of reproductive rights for women's liberty
or for their capacity to participate
as equal members in our nation.
The dissent notes that Alito still thought
it was necessary to trace
hostility to abortion,
and of course, the women's
rights back to the 1300s.
Justice Alito relied
heavily on the writings
of people like Matthew
Hale, a British jurist
who presided at early
American witch trials
and believed women were
property of their husbands.
And the dissent doesn't
see why Hale's writings
or any thoughts by people
before the Revolutionary War
should play a role in
what is acceptable today.
Quote, "First, it is
not clear what relevance
such early history should
have even to the majority."
And then the Court cites
the Bruen gun rights case,
which was decided last week,
where the Court held that,
quote, "Historical evidence
that long predates
ratification may not illuminate
the scope of the right."
And the last bit is a dig at
the majority opinion in Bruen,
where the same justices
who overruled Roe and Casey
concluded that when it came to guns,
it didn't actually matter
if the people were allowed
to carry concealed firearms
prior to ratification
of the Second Amendment.
And the dissent accuses the majority
of picking and choosing the history
that supports the outcome they want.
Quote, "If early history
obviously supported
abortion rights, the
majority would no doubt say
that only the views of the
14th Amendment's ratifiers
were germane."
And many people have accused Alito
of this sort of Goldilocks
quasi historical analysis,
that the rights can't be too old
and they also can't be too new.
Roe has been the law for 50
years and that does not qualify,
according to Alito, as
being deeply rooted.
And the leaked draft attracted
attention from historians
who said that Alito got the
early history of abortion wrong.
Many states Alito listed
as banning all abortion
actually banned it only after quickening
and did not make abortion criminal at all.
The same historical evidence made it
into the official majority opinion.
But the dissenters took note
of this controversy, saying,
quote, "Embarrassingly for the majority,
early law in fact does
provide some support
for abortion rights.
Common-law authorities
did not treat abortion
as a crime before quickening,
the point when the fetus
has moved in the womb.
And early American law
followed the common-law rule.
So the criminal law of that early time
might be taken as roughly consonant
with Roe's and Casey's different treatment
of early and late abortions."
And this is often a
controversy when you're talking
about originalism.
In some sense, both the majority
and the dissent are correct.
At many times in American
history but not all,
states criminalized abortions.
And at many times in American history,
abortion was permitted, and
not just in the 20th century.
This just shows how difficult it is
to use historical evidence
to find the right
interpretation of the text.
And since early American law allowed
for legal abortion before quickening,
the dissent says Alito
focuses on modern law
where he concludes that
because most states
criminalized abortion in the
decades before Roe was decided,
the right wasn't deeply rooted.
And again, the dissent
points out the majority
for the perceived hypocrisy,
given the Bruen decision.
Quote, "Had the pre-Roe
liberalization of abortion laws
occurred more quickly and more
widely in the 20th century,
the majority would say once again
that only the ratifiers
views are germane."
And the dissent ends by accusing Alito
of erasing women and their
interest from its opinion.
Quote, "The majority would
allow states to ban abortion
from conception onwards
because it does not think
forced childbirth at all
implicates women's rights
to equality and freedom.
Today's Court, that is, does
not think there is anything
of constitutional significance attached
to a woman's control of her
body and the path of her life.
Roe and Casey thought that
one-sided view misguided.
In some sense, that is a
difference in a nutshell
between our precedence
and the majority opinion.
The constitutional regime we have lived in
for the last 50 years
recognized competing interests,
and sought to balance between them.
The constitutional regime we enter today
erases the woman's interest and recognizes
only the state's or the
Federal Government's."
Now, the dissent tears
into the majority's
stare decisis analysis,
noting that, quote, "The Court
may not overrule a decision,
even a constitutional one,
without a special justification."
And as to the other factors,
whether the standard is workable,
whether there have been
changes in the law or fact,
and whether women relied
on the right to abortion,
the dissent takes Alito to task.
Quote, "The standards
Roe and Casey set out
are perfectly workable.
No changes in either law or fact
have eroded the two decisions.
And tens of millions of American women
have relied and continued to
rely on the right to abortion.
So under traditional
stare decisis principles,
the majority has no special justification
for the harm it causes."
And according to the dissent, quote,
"The majority comes close
to conceding that point.
The majority barely mentions any legal
or factual changes that have
occurred since Roe and Casey.
It suggests the two
decisions are hard for courts
to implement, but cannot prove its case.
In the end, the majority
says, all it must say
to override stare decisis is one thing,
that it believes Roe and
Casey egregiously wrong.
That rule could equally spell
the end of any precedent
with which a bare majority of
the present court disagrees."
And the dissent makes
a legal realism point
incredibly bluntly.
Quote, "The majority has
overruled Roe and Casey
for one and only one reason,
because it has always despised them,
and now it has the votes to discard them.
The majority thereby
substitutes a rule by judges
for the rule of law."
Now, I know a lot of people
are upset about this decision,
and we'll talk more about what
can be done in the future.
But one thing you can do right now
is that there is a
company that I work with
called Tab for Cause,
which lets you raise money
for charity just by opening
tabs and browsing the internet.
Now, Tabs for a Cause
responded to your request,
and they just launched Tab
for Reproductive Health,
which lets you raise money
for nonprofit organizations
protecting and providing access
to reproductive healthcare,
like the Center for Reproductive Rights
and Planned Parenthood.
I know this is just a little thing,
but it's something that
you can do right now.
The way it works is that Tab for a Cause
is a browser extension that allows you
to pick the charity of your choice.
Then every time you open up a new tab,
instead of displaying a blank page,
it displays a customizable
tab with a couple of tiny ads.
And the money that you generate
is then given to the
charity of your choice.
You can see in real time how
much money is being generated
and you can even customize this tab
the way that you like it.
And LegalEagle tabers alone have raised
over $35,000 for charity.
I know this because "Tab
for a Cause's finances
are a hundred percent transparent.
So you can see for yourself
how much you've raised
and where it's gone.
So if that sounds interesting to you,
if you'd like to make a
very small difference,
all you have to do is click on the link
that's on screen right
now or in the description,
and install the browser extension.
And that's it.
Then every page that you
open will create revenue
that goes to charity.
So all you have to do is click on the link
that's on screen right
now or in the description
to install the browser extension.
That's it.
And then every page you
open will create revenue
that goes to charity.
So all you have to do is click
on the link that's on screen.
And we'll talk about more in the future
what else you can do in the
wake of the Dobbs decision.